she goes you want me to make a run for
you there's a liquor store right by here
and I go I don't know she goes I'll make
a run I don't know if I need to drink
juice you need to drink you want it you
like it you love it you want some more
Tito's
you were actually on the Johnny Carson
show you got you were one of those
comedians that I guess it was after
Saturday Night Live what was it before
[ __ ] Fred when did he retire oh [ __ ] is
it 92. I don't know because I did it two
months before he retired wow so whenever
that was so maybe you were already on
Saturday Night Live I mean retired in uh
May of 92. okay thanks Benji
um
so so I yeah I had to go out and I got
the spot and the talent guy goes when
you go out there you hit the mark
you do your [ __ ] crummy jokes and you
come right back is that what he said
yeah he goes come on just do it and I go
I heard Johnny waves you over if you're
really good that's not gonna happen I
wouldn't worry about that just do your
[ __ ] come back come right to me like a
puppy you know come on come here like
he's right in the curtains Show's so
[ __ ] uptight I've never even done I
was like sure meanwhile I went out there
and [ __ ] a [ __ ] brick because
you don't even realize you're looking at
cameras it's different than you see on
TV so all your mind does is go right to
that like oh my God look at these
cameras the floor is so shiny you start
to look around and see how artificial it
all and I go it's so small in here yeah
wait am I doing my act like I like I was
like do I have to do [ __ ] so anyway I
see the little X got it found the X look
back thumbs up guys like uh what a
rookie and then Carson's a little behind
you to the right so it's hard because
you can't really just look at them do
you remember your act from what you did
I think I go hey uh I got a new uh car
uh
uh it's a UPS truck I actually just got
a second Park where everyone
and uh did that did that get some laughs
oh yeah not like it just died
actually did well because I have a good
crowd right so then uh anyway I did a
couple of those and then a couple
zingers threw in a few doozies and then
I finished but I did pretty good yeah so
I look to the right and wave but I can't
even see him because I don't look all
the way to the right and use his Martin
Short
and they cut to Martin Short they go hey
he was great Martin sure goes yeah get
him over here and he goes yeah come here
and Johnny waves me over and I turn and
leave oh and he goes what's he doing oh
he did he doesn't okay he's not coming
over all right he just left okay I gotta
go back I gotta go back and watch that
isn't that weird so then I get back and
the drunk guy in the backup what are you
doing he waved you're like [ __ ] you you
told me don't even look at the guy yeah
you were in the mindset that like you
just had to return to the back of the
stage it was not an option you were told
to return like a dog I'm [ __ ] Lassie
I get backstage and then they knock in
the door and have my shirt off right it
was like a freaking Bo blowout like
blowing down trees like during a
hurricane and I opened the door I go
what my shirt off holding a jug of
Pepto-Bismol Johnny doc
uh and Martin Short oh my goodness and I
go holy [ __ ] and Johnny goes hey you ran
off I just want to say good job you're
funny I kind of froze and then uh he
looks at my Pepto-Bismol and go I'm
trying to quit this stuff I was sorry I
was nervous because hey me too and then
he left and that was it
dude I did you a favor you know how you
called me up and you said you love
Beetlejuice yeah I brought him in for
you yeah
look at that yeah
you have that shirt yeah
look at how slow he walks in what a stud
I want to get a good shot he walks in
like Apollo Creed walked in a rocket
Beetlejuice has a lot of confidence
anyway so uh David Spade is a big fan of
yours this is David Spade what's up
buddy he's a big fan of yours he wanted
to meet you he called me up and he said
he wanted to meet you David you're not
that much taller than Beetlejuice no I'm
not no
he's cooler though who has a better
build David Spade or Beetlejuice Robin
Beetlejuice has a better shirt on I was
looking at Beetlejuice has broad
shoulders the Beetlejuice is in good
shape you work out yeah I'll work out
yeah what do you do what's your routine
180 pounds over you work out with a
trainer yeah I best press well 25. 125.
sweet put it up dude all right nice
that's more than Howard does you're damn
right it is you bench and what else
squats squats Squad light 5 30. 530
pounds yeah because that sounds a little
high he could change that number at any
time I like when he interviewed him and
he was on a movie set and you go what's
the movie about he goes I don't know
tell me about the movie what's this
movie about I don't know I don't know
gotta ask them I don't know do you know
you know what your scene's about your
character I don't know I don't got
nothing to do with this do you know your
character's name in the movie I don't
know you gotta ask them I don't know you
gotta ask these guys I don't know
nothing
what is that movie coming out of yours
is it really yeah it's totally out it's
all right it's already out I got the
stories about it because your movie
hasn't come out yet it's a big it's a
big movie it takes out how to do it yeah
nobody could have played this part but
you though right Beetle yeah all the
Paul I can play yeah just thanks for
waking up early and coming and hanging
with me buddy
oh it's this girl catch me outside girl
yeah who is to catch me outside girl oh
she was on Dr Phil okay catch me outside
I played the tape for you she was just
this girl and so and she got into a
fight with an audience member yeah and
so she's like a tough Street chick yeah
now I saw her out and my friend goes hey
that's catch me outside girl which is
her official name pretty much right
right and I go oh yeah and so he goes I
want to get a picture with her so let's
go over there she'll know Joe Dirt or
something she'll get a picture with you
sure so we go over there a lot of
pressure on you yeah she's she's with
her mom and like a body a bodyguard I
think she's 14. she's got a bodyguard
yeah she she looks like she's 30. right
so by the way they're perfectly Pleasant
they do know Joe Dirt we talk we all
take pictures fine and then I'm the
[ __ ] because a couple days later I go
I'm gonna put that picture of that girl
people might remember that she's the
catcher it's funny then I go okay I give
her a little slam I go uh unfortunately
this picture was taken five minutes
after she stopped being famous right and
then you see I
I let's say my regular picture gets like
20 or 30 000 likes right right within 20
minutes I look at my phone it says 30
000 I go
what's going on shaking my phone like
and then I look on it and now there's
fights because I made fun of her so her
fans are coming on going [ __ ] you and
who the who are you even about oh my God
and then now I'm getting scared like I'm
in this her bees are buzzing out like
they came at me and then the next day
she goes
she puts it up or comments on it who
diss thought you was my waiter oh it's
kind of funny show yeah that's not a bad
company you know I didn't know if your
team needed 48 hours to come up with
that one but fine you got to be so witty
when it comes to these wars on these
songs oh my God believe me I tapped out
I go I'm losing and then like she's more
famous than you should I was like really
so I look at she has 10 million
followers oh my God I have a million I
go well maybe she's more famous if you
go by facts
it's an amazing career you have because
you've gone from Once you went from
Saturday Night Live to movies that that
did extremely well you know with well
Farley uh you know yeah Tommy Boy Joe
Dirt there's ones that have done better
than others yeah you're right who's the
genius that figured that YouTube guys
would be good in the first movie who who
the who that was Lauren was it Lauren
who said hey you guys should make a
movie together he said
he told two writers that write a movie
about these guys the way they act around
the office like Farley has a room with
spade and then he Spades like the fake
smart one and Farley walks behind him
and asks him questions and then I make
fun of them and then it's sort of like
the Three Stooges cup yeah it was always
smarter than the other yeah fake smarter
and then uh uh but I was always like
uh in awe that he was so good and almost
didn't know it so even in movies like
Tommy Boy the only thing I could bring
to that is saying why don't I'm
remembering bits and pieces he would say
over the weeks or years that were funny
and just go there's actually one line we
got to work in because you said it two
weeks ago or fat guy in a little coat
let's let's try to put that in the movie
Somewhere even though it's so dumb but I
think people think it's funny if we do
and little weird things and gestures and
funny faces we would because he did him
so uh casually that I would try to log
him in my head and go God that's going
to be great and I didn't know Lauren
Michaels looked at the two of you guys
and said this will be a great movie I
mean that's brilliant that was a great
call because if you think about it we
never could have pitched that movie if
you went to Paramount and said two guys
drive across Ohio and try to sell brake
pads he's the dumbest idea in the world
yeah I mean that's just silly yeah I
mean how long does it take to shoot a
movie like that it was pretty quick but
we shot it during siren live and who
wrote the script A Bonnie and Terry
Turner and then Fred Wolfe who have
worked with a million times since has
done it right he sort of turned into my
writing partner since but it was punched
up and then we went to Toronto and we
would do you know SNL on Saturday we'd
fly in a jet to Toronto we'd shoot all
Sunday maybe that's what made the movie
great because you guys you guys don't
have to think it through so much it's
like almost like Hey we're in the middle
of Saturday Night Live we gotta go shoot
this movie and you know you don't you
don't put too much energy in one in
place getting neurotic about it but then
maybe the pressure of that is too much I
don't know you know one time I got
skinnier and he got fatter I know that
for sure yeah see something's going on
Lauren goes well at least it stays on
the screen yeah the same way did you
ever watch the old movies or the two
people I mean they're on so much that
you get caught up in them and it's sort
of sad and fun because you remember the
whole day of the shoot you remember
right one day going uh let's bring a
little clip-on tie and say it's a
clip-on and you go really and then we go
let's just try to put that in somewhere
in the scene because you'd see that many
sides for the next day and go this feels
a little flat what can we do that is
stupid like housekeeping from Tommy Boy
I would do every morning when I came to
his room I'd go housekeeping and he'd go
housekeeping and he goes the [ __ ] out of
here put that [ __ ] thing on the door
and I go housekeeping he goes God damn
it then he'd open the door oh it's you
do you know I do this every morning
Chris when you do that stuff in real
life and it's funny and then you go to
try it on film you don't know for sure
and we were just like left alone in
Toronto doing time boys so we'd wake up
and the director and one of the writers
and go can we just try this and and the
director of Pete Siegel is great because
sometimes
because he didn't know us well but
sometimes he go I trust you guys if you
think this is funny I go I don't know
but made us laugh last night and The
Carpenter's singing and stuff we do
anyway we go if it done right I think
people will think it's funny too
I did an Indian casino recently oh yeah
my last gig I just did it's funny
because you know no it's an Indian
casino is that like a dry situation
where you don't it was so I bring these
little Tito bottles of uh vodka like
little airplane ones maybe one or two in
the socks just to keep the party going
so I fly you know to this casino what a
[ __ ] whatever fine good for me yeah I
gotta make those Honda Accord payments
somehow you know absolutely Honda
accord's a nice car pay for the serious
yeah so I get I get land I gotta drive
an hour and then the lady's like a tough
sort of older woman like been around the
block been there forever
she goes ah another gig for you huh I go
yep yep so we we get there and then she
goes there's no dressing room this is
your RV in the parking lot I go God it's
like some crummy RV it's 102 for real so
it's sizzling I get in there and then
wispy wallet I'm getting sunburned
through the wall I'm like God damn this
can't be happening and then she goes
knock knock Meanwhile my driver uh
ideally would be in the car right but
she comes in and goes hey probably not
supposed to come in here I just want to
give you a heads up it's a dry Casino
like I'm [ __ ] Foster Brooks uh she's
about 70. and she's your driver yeah wow
so I go oh yeah I go I hurt I go you
know what I had a hunch so I slipped in
me Tito's in my socks I got two and she
was not gonna do it I go well you know I
weigh 140 I think I'll be right
and then I go I'll just have some at
dinner and she goes dry restaurant I go
[ __ ] actually got her finger on the
pulse of the booze in this town so I go
oh [ __ ] really I go I should be all
right so I go I come out I got a little
bit of a buzz but I come out she knocks
again how you feeling party boy I go she
goes you want me to make a run for you
there's a liquor store right by here and
I go I don't know she goes I'll make a
run I don't know if I need a drink juice
you need to drink you want it you like
it you love it you want some more Tito's
so I go uh all right so she goes I'll do
a covert run I go I don't think anyone
gives a [ __ ] you know so she goes all
right I'll go I'll go I go okay Jason
Bourne so she sneaks off she comes back
in and she goes okay I got some stuff
for the talent and then she knocks in I
got it I got it I go all right drug
dealer yeah so then she goes here's your
Abba Zaba she had to water it down a bit
yeah uh here's here's a comb a yo-yo and
then she goes reaches in a bra here's
your Tito out of her bra one tea to the
other one she's like Yay gonna go nope
that's me nip all right here's your
other Tito puts it down and then uh I go
oh gross thanks and then she goes uh hey
slug him I go no no no she goes get your
Buzz get out there and bring the funny
and I go who is this I I don't know and
I go I got it from here I got it from
here so anyway I go to the show Crush
kill whatever other people's words
standing out but anyway the only
embarrassing thing I ordered a jet to
get me home because it's pretty far away
I'm working on the show I go I want to
come home late I get a crowbar on the
wall and I go let's get a jet fine so me
and Bobby my my opener guy we look at
you we get in the back of the Sprinter
and I'm like conked out you know because
it's showing Buzz is fading away now I'm
more into cranky mode and then she goes
it's usually how it goes the trajectory
so then she goes where where I go as
fast as you can just got to get to the
airport yeah yeah and then two months
later can I ask a favor I don't know if
we're at the favor level of this
relationship I go what is he goes this
could get me fired
I don't know she goes my granddaughter
I'm a grandma shocker yeah uh I she's 11
loves Joe Dirt says all the quotes does
all the I go you want me to call her she
goes no can we pop over there for a
second oh she's just a couple clicks off
the freeway I go clicks
sounds far she goes nah just a little
zigzag then a beep bop boop and then
we're right there I go uh
and I never do this because I'm [ __ ]
great guy syndrome but I go I I can't I
go we got to get there and they got to
take off at certain time she goes yeah
yeah like she's already [ __ ] grousing
yeah and so I go all right and then I
start to Zonk out again two seconds
later
he's right here hold on you're on I'm
like [ __ ] and it's a FaceTime I go Jesus
oh my God so I'm crawling to the front
and she's like sticking it through that
little window swerving
that's him look and so I go oh hi I
crawl up I you know she's like hi I'm
like hey you watch the movie you know
whatever I say and then I see the chick
look at me like she's like I am up the
funny you're bombing I'm bombing I'm
doing my and she goes give her some
stuff from the movie I'm like hey dang
you know what's crapping and kids like
couldn't give a [ __ ] and then and then
she takes the phone away from me she
goes he's tired he's tired I'll call you
later oh my God you bombed and like get
the worst review from Grandma [ __ ] that
kid she was like Cindy Brady freezing up
on me she didn't help me at all
I was at a hotel and then I think it was
Four Seasons something nice but I
ordered
a massage just a couple years ago and
and I hear of course I order a girl you
know it's almost given but I yeah you
forget sometimes you go oh yeah it's
Gotta Be girl and then on the door I go
uh-oh um is everything okay out here and
then I looked through to the people and
there's this huge Russian Dolph Lundgren
guy and I God I keep the little chain on
I go all right is there what's going on
he goes I go you're looking for the gym
or the steroid room he goes and this is
I go oh no no I don't I don't no I'm
sorry it's been a horrible mistake I
ordered a girl and he goes no no I'm
Teddy Bear right well you ordered a
woman but I'm only one left today and
I'm uh and I go and he goes but
you pay either way I go ah I'll try it
okay one time money was involved yeah so
I I let him in stupidly why do you have
to pay either way you specified a woman
it's not yours I don't fight all right
yeah I know it's embarrassing you're
gonna fight I don't fight anything so
then he comes in aren't you on TV I
never complained do you ever complain
during massage I don't even if it's
horrible so I won't complain so Because
You're vulnerable
all right well be careful you know
because he's a monster so he puts me on
the table like a [ __ ] rag doll he
just like lays me on there and he goes
now any problems you tell me yeah
and then he's like
like he's pushing me right away I feel
like my C4 through nine is like like
fireworks uh uh okay and then I go I
don't want to say anything but it's
obviously 300 times too hard but he's
like doing a handstand I go hey and I
finally go hey it's a little uh it's a
little too and he goes
I go he [ __ ] shushed me wow and I was
so stunned in that little face plate my
eyes were oh I go did he do what did he
just say now he's like still smashing my
face through that thing like Silly Putty
and my shoulders are jammed I mean so
much more pain already within five
seconds and he's like going down on my
of my lower back of my spine so I try
again I go
hey maybe 20 less
told me to shut up again [ __ ] Doppler
and I shut the [ __ ] up for an hour while
he beat the [ __ ] out of me oh my God and
then he left and I just laid there like
I was in [ __ ] 1917.
all right